the way I would describe what I do is I
teach political philosophy and what that
really amounts to is inviting students
to reflect critically on their own moral
and political convictions to figure out
what they believe in why and to do that
in the company of some of the great
philosophers of the past so so I invite
students to to read some of the famous
works of political philosophy but with
an eye to contemporary challenges and
dilemmas and above all with an eye to
sorting out as students very very much
water do to sort out their own moral and
religious convictions their own take on
the world that's that's really what I do